I'm just a girl that loves fashion.
So when we got invited to the CFDA Awards by Ralph Lauren,
I obviously said yes and got on the next flight out.
Tonight we're getting ready for it.
My nails were embarrassing,
so I had to get my nails done.
Hair and makeup, I'm very selective with who I let touch my face,
but Yasmin, my makeup artist,
just got back from tour, so I was so happy.
Made it out to New York to glam me for tonight.
Little whimsy Lou came with us to New York.
Obviously had to hang out while we were doing glam.
Got the dress tailored the night before,
so we were trying it on to see whether it fit.
So glad it fits so well. Right before leaving,
lucky got whimsy to sleep,
did the finishing touches,
and then we were out the door.
I always get a little bit of social anxiety
when it comes to events like these,
so I'm so glad that lucky and I can do them together.
We got there. I was so in awe of this museum and the Dinosaur skeletons,
and little me was geeking out,
and just a little science girl at heart.
We walked the carpet, got the pictures,
and then it was time to sit down and have my first chicken pot pie
and enjoy the rest of the night.